santiago hola un saludo grande desde
colombia y si lamentable lamentable la
situación que vivimos el día de ayer en
bogotá entre los hinchas de santa fe y
de nacional inaceptable unos cuantos
vándalos disfrazados de hinchas se
tomaron el estadio y dañaron esta fiesta
que era pacífica desafortunadamente hubo
heridos policías heridos personas
heridas
toda la nuestra solidaridad con ellos
pero creo que hay que trabajar en varios
frentes hay que trabajar en varios
frentes para controlar la impunidad en
este tipo de eventos yo creo que muchos
de estos vándalos están acostumbrados a
salir sin castigo y lo que es hora de
que el fútbol en colombia actualice sus
medidas tecnológicas para poder
individualizar conocer y saber quién
está ingresando a los estadios y de esta
manera poder controlar y evitar que los
vándalos vuelvan a entrar lo que se va a
hacer parte del centro del debate lo que
hay que hacer en colombia y es
verdaderamente establecer medidas que
nos permitan controlar el ingreso de
personas indeseables a los estadios y el
otro tema muy importante desde el
gobierno nacional es trabajar
jóvenes trabajar con las barras pues los
líderes positivos a partir de proyectos
que nos permitan identificar una mejor
organización social de las personas en
los aficionados del fútbol ahora además
de bueno de todas estas posibles medidas
no que son muy interesantes qué
novedades hay en la investigación hay
personas identificadas o detenidas
ya se han identificado algunas personas
especialmente uno de los hinchas de
nacional que agredió a un joven
aficionado el santa fe- a patadas en la
cabeza ya fue identificado y esperamos
que las autoridades aquí en colombia
aquí en bogotá sigan avanzando con éxito
en nuestras investigaciones por otro
lado este adelantaba algunas de las
posibles medidas pero creo que la
ausencia de público en el estadio podría
ser una solución aunque por el contrario
podría agravar la situación y violentar
más los ánimos de los hinchas
yo creo santiago que ese tipo de medidas
se han ensayado muchas veces alguna vez
se escuche que se puede llamar locos a
aquellos que siempre intentan la misma
medida esperando una solución diferente
un resultado diferente yo creo que
tenemos que buscar otras formas es más
fácil cerrar los estadios y sin dudas y
la indisciplina continuar pues ese será
el castigo que recibirán que recibirán
los hinchas pero yo creo que hay que
pensar en el mediano plazo a2 35 años yo
creo que hoy uno se puede subir a un
avión y para subvención avión uno compra
un tiquete uno escoge la silla donde se
va a sentar y uno se presenta al counter
con un código qr y con su documento de
identificación y lo dejan entrar lo
mismo debe pasar en los estadios además
con acompañamiento de la policía para
poder individualizar y depurar aquellas
personas que no deben ser admitidas en
los estadios y se armará a castagno a
ministra del deporte de colombia
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
francés 24